I've come together with the one oh my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter bone sisters helped to feed those
who are in poor conditions and who don't
even have a clothing to keep themselves
warm your small donation might mean
nothing to you but it can change their
life and help them survive the winter
this year
a central Doctrine in Islam but but it's
and and this is why perhaps I found God
the way I did because I understood all
these things first and then I saw the
Quran and confirmed so many things for
me you know like I've even the
conversations I've been having so far so
many things have been confirmed and it's
amazing the knowledge that's inside of
it which is so applicable today yeah for
for an old book right you know it's
supposed to be old but it seems so so
Timeless but it's truly amazing but
you're you're totally right and and the
Baseline morality I don't think most
people understand that when they're
doing this under the guise of Tolerance
when they're saying be so tolerant that
you no longer believe in right from
wrong they're not doing that to make
Society a better place they're doing
that to empty your brain so that you
have no resistance to the slave mind
programming they want to get you to a
point where if they tell you the sky is
green yeah you look at with your own
eyes yeah and you see blue but no the
sky is green that's what they want so
that you have to have nothing in your
brain that